in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tim and
Terra are with us hey how are you guys
how are you excited awesome welcome
where are you from we are from Shawnee
Kansas just outside of Kansas City Oh
Shawnee Mission right Shawnee
yes Shawnee right there by it okay very
cool welcome welcome and so you're here
to do a debt-free scream how much have
you paid off we have paid off two
hundred thousand seven hundred and
seventeen dollars and twenty-five cents
two hundred thousand seven hundred okay
very cool very cool and how long did it
take you to do that exactly one year
whoa
and your household income during that
year right around 200 okay there you go
all right so what kind of debt was this
we had a extra house that was Tims
before we got married that we bought in
oh six and tried to sell no nine so that
wasn't happening so we carried that for
a few years of them we had a awesome
timeshare mm-hmm car and credit cards
and then a roof that we had to put on
the house in order to sell it
gotcha okay so the house sold we did
nothing for the beginning what did it
sell for how much about a hundred and
fourteen okay so hundred fourteen of the
200 was the deal yes and then the rest
of it you just pounded in cash flowed
over the last year yes you got it
okay very cool very cool well
congratulations
so what started this journey a year ago
what's what flipped what what switch
flipped everyone its hell yeah you know
laying awake at night knowing how much
we owed everybody and feeling a bit
trapped that we had to have the income
that we had in order to make those
payments mm-hmm yeah making two hundred
and feeling broke and cool no it's not
that's and so you know somebody actually
had gifted me the the FPU online mm-hmm
about four months before we actually
started I signed up and then I didn't do
anything with it and then I got the
email that said you have ten days to
finish our subscription and as you know
there's nine one-hour videos that we had
to get through so I actually watched the
first one by myself and when I got to
the second one and it talked about the
relational part about money I went to
Tim and I said I
need you to to watch this with me we had
been married for six years at that point
and we hadn't joined our money together
here laziness on my part my bank was in
another city and but you know we just
decided that that we needed to do this
he watched that and then we just powered
through the rest of those videos binge
watched Netflix thing as we were taking
walks through the neighborhood we had it
playing on our iPhone I loved it that's
cool nothing like an email to just okay
I'm about to lose my my gift here it
didn't cost you anything but you can't
let it get away exactly for you good for
you I like that very nice very good job
well congratulations you all thank you
so that caused you to just all of a
sudden I mean you power through those
gets power through those videos in a
week or in ten days and yeah I guess you
guys just went all-in then huh a hundred
percent that's all we could do we had so
much debt and there's coming our ears
and we just said enough is enough
yeah and it was right about that time
that we are we had some renters in our
home that we were renting and they got
evicted because they've been missing
some payments and we're like okay this
is our opportunity the market was great
at that time and so it was it was truly
a blessing that we saw that house sale
sell and your every dollar app came out
literally the month that we started this
I think God knew that my spreadsheet was
a little too complicated and said there
you go get you started but yeah it was
pretty awesome I mean even we were kind
of like oh we can't take the kids to do
things and we found money yeah we really
once we started using that app we just
found money in we were able to do the
things that we really wanted to do what
was the thing you did that when you were
doing it it felt the weirdest while
you're getting out of debt it's like I
feel like I feel strange when I'm doing
this I think actually going and I think
just doing the budget at first we were
very much rearview mirror and not
windshield so but I don't know if it was
real we're maybe it was weird to other
people but I I was excited to like look
online for any like payments that came
automatically so I could go
my app and it was just so you know which
one's the nerd clearly but you know just
going through that and I think we found
opportunities to in get involved at
church where you know events where
normally others we're having to pay
tickets where it will volunteer and help
out so we could still be part of it but
it didn't come out of our pocketbook
well congratulations you guys very very
well done
now you've got your two kids with you we
do all right and their ages and names
Fletcher is six and Lorelei is three all
right all right and have they been
practicing their debt free screams oh
yes of course all right beautiful look
at those curls all right see those of
you that aren't watching this on YouTube
or watching it at home on on the Dave
Ramsey show app you didn't get to see
this but a beautiful family well done
all right Tim and Tara Fletcher and
Lauri and Lorelei is two hundred and one
thousand dollars paid off including the
sale of one hundred and fourteen
thousand dollar house all done in one
year making two hundred a year
wonderful job very proud of you we're
gonna give you a copy of Chris Hogan's
book signed copy retire inspired number
one bestseller and of course that's the
next stage for you now that you've done
this you're you're out of that you can
build wealth and be outrageously
generous so the plan that's the plan
count it down let's hear a great debt
free scream three two one way to go guys
boom just like that very very very well
done man that's powerful stuff hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a $500,000 in economy
you